vous avez une question posée comme tous
les soirs puisque c'est encore vous qui
avez gagné allez-y je ne la connais pas
et je répondrai à toutes vos questions
c'est vrai qu'il ya deux jours vous a
répondu avec courage et brio à une
question un peu compliqué mais nous a
été honnête mais ce soir ce pass une
étape supérieure
ce soir c'est la ligue des champions ah
oui à ce soir va pas falloir se débiner
alors je vais vous dire un truc vous
faites pas de petit chef dans le monde
mais c'est pas la même
[Applaudissements]
répondre à la question m ouais j'ai une
question
alors pour certains la réponse sera
évidente comme jean-michel l'activité
sur deux tables à chelsea il va me
lâcher sur ce soir vous pouvez donner
non pas le numéro de benjamin mais quand
chez chacun des chroniqueurs un défaut
bien sûr seul le plus gros défaut dans
ces cas là bernard montiel fénéon
mais rajouter sans mentir quoi au nom
des familles juives et mon frère malade
l'hypocrite lacaille et c'est bon jean
michel maire très feignons christine
kelly je ne vois presque pas de défaut
aux si je devais en dire
elle est aux cieux enfin pas trop trop
consciencieux elle s'affirme elle
s'affirme pas ça parce que on a envie
d'avoir encore plus ses trousses
[Rires]
isabelle ou avec moi isabelle isabelle
houde ce que choisir
jamel il amène c'est son manque de
franchise surtout sur géraldine maillet
vous le savez elles lytro n'y a pas de
défaut et les mc et home accueille les
trop grandes arkema ake pa et physique
c'est pas vrai nom vous est non alors
juste géraldine maillet peut-être elle
est non c est les normes n'est pas
fainéant d'anciens non non alors t'es tu
n'as fait ça elle est têtue c'est vrai
elle était serré on a plus prendre la
tête avec les regrets oui mais vous
aimez bien quand même parce que disait
donc non je repense on s'aime beaucoup
quand même vertbaudet francesca c'est
une taille mais on adore voilà comme ça
mais le cvec benjamin castaldi cassany
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui arriva
est ce que tu veux vraiment dû m'énerve
pas encore voilà alors un square et
calme-toi son principal défaut à benji
je mesure n'est trop généreux oui c'est
bon hommes et femmes et parce que ça
peut jouer des tours parfois samantha
jouer voilà exaucé moi et j'ai dit la
vérité et les il est comme ça trop
fidèle au c'est vous vous et vous jouez
trop fine elle peut être concis et ça ça
voudra arrivera jamais ça
[Rires]
keddy son principal défaut alors
l'insolence et j'avoue je déteste moulin
oui j'aurais jamais pensé ça ah bah moi
pas changé vous auriez pensé quoi trop
bavarde aussi non mais y en a beaucoup
et vous attend soit trop de questions tu
te la pètes un peu parce que tu es mon
petit préféré
merci jimi hope i 4
[Applaudissements]